[Music]
hey GQ I'm Haley Bieber and these are my
Essentials so I'm going to be taking you
through my 10 travel Essentials that I
have to have with me every single time
I'm
[Music]
traveling this is my road peptide
glazing fluid glazing milk and barrier
restore cream the way I actually
conceptualized the items and the
products I was going to have for road
was in the thought of if I was going on
a plane what would be like the necessary
things I would need to have with me and
that was when we first launched it was
just this the cream and the peptide lip
treatment and now we have the glazing
milk but the thought was always what
would I absolutely need to have with me
on a flight and that is these items so
our glazing milk which is our hydrating
Essence our peptide glazing fluid which
is our gel serum and our berry restore
cream just to keep the skin really
really fresh and dewy and glowy and
protected on the plain ride men this is
for you too don't think that my husband
doesn't use all of these as
[Music]
well this is perfume obviously this is
the ex niilo lust in Paradise probably
like my third bottle of this as you can
see it's been used but every time I
travel when I'm going to be on the plane
I like to have perfume with me because
you know just to freshen up and smell
nice so I like to keep that in my
bag I think it very much lives up to the
name it's called lust in Paradise it
smells kind of beachy and
floraly think
Hawaii kind of a
Vibe my next essential
is a travel lint roller this one is
brand new I haven't opened it yet but
when I'm on a plan plain long flights I
like to be curled up in a really like
fuzzy cozy blanket sometimes it's not
the best thing for clothes so this is a
fun little emergency thing to have for
fuzzies you can't go wrong with a great
pair of sunnies these are just easy
black St lauron
Sunglasses if I really like a pair of
sunglasses I try to get multiple pairs
because I have done dogs and sometimes
they get chewed up and ruined so I have
probably at least like two or three
pairs of these on
Deck peptide lip treatment this one is
the clear version which is just like my
all-time favorite go-to this is our
strawberry glaze scent that I'm obsessed
with this is my favorite flavor and this
is our peptide lip tint which is new
these are our tinted version of the
peptide lip treatment I love this fresh
nudie color and the reason I like to
have both is because I just don't know
what my mood is going to be and
sometimes I want a little color
sometimes I just want hydration maybe
it's like the clear for the plain ride
and then the color when I get to where
I'm going so I do like to have both with
me at all
[Music]
times scrunchie um I sometimes just get
annoyed having my hair in my face want
to be able to put my hair back I put a
lot of skin care on on the plane so I
need to be able to get my hair out of my
face and I just always like having a
scrunchie with me it's either on my
wrist or in my bag don't go anywhere
without a scrunchie I don't know if I
have a lucky scrunchie I definitely have
ones I've had for a really long time
though since I was like a teenager that
I still use this day this is not one of
them but we love this
one in the same world of hair items this
little mini brush my hair gets really
really Tangled and naughty especially if
I'm like tossing and turning sleeping on
a flight I'm kind of picturing this is
like a really long flight I'm going
somewhere far away I like to have a
brush with me kind of everywhere I go
because you just never know when you're
going to need
it so this you can see has been used
this is just a really pretty nude lip
liner that I also like to keep with me
because I feel like if I at least can do
a lip it brings some life to the face
after a long long flx cuz at least if I
have sunglasses and then I can do a lip
I can live with that so this is the uh
Makeup Forever pencil in anywhere
caffeine which is my
[Music]
favorite these are Drew slippers I love
to bring Slippers With Me on the plane
because they're just cozy these ones
specifically are just my favorite and
really really really really comfortable
so must
have this is a little compact mirror of
course need it to apply my skin care
apply my lip combos whatever you know I
think a mirror is pretty
self-explanatory so just this little
mirror and that was it the mirror was
the 10th item so there you go my travel
Essentials those are my 10 Essentials
thank you so much for watching and I'll
see you next
time